between magnus carlsen and lee emlay and
magnus carlsen up by one point white
pieces in game three if he wins it he's
going to be ready for the semi-finals
what do you think about the position we
are seven moves into the game it's
already very sharp this is an opening
battle it's a battle of homework um this
opening came from the ragosan defense
something we've seen several times
throughout the tour it's a variation of
the queen's gambit but now talking of
queens they're just about to leave the
board and there we go the queens have
been traded it's a really weird pawn
structure if you look at the c file
white has a pawn black has a pawn white
has a pawn
those pawns stacked up there probably a
few of them are going to drop off but
meanwhile black challenging white dark
squared bishop and the more traits we
see the more likely it will mean that
black is feeling safe then again i
prefer white because at the very minimum
now you could just use your bishop
capture the black knight and then you
can use your other bishop white's bishop
next to the king zoom out and
temporarily go upon up it feels like
liam has done his homework just by the
speed he's playing but he does have some
questions to answer white will be a pawn
up in this game um
double pawns
that's the problem for white pawn up but
the quality of the pawns is not good
those white pawns those on the c file
they're doubled and troubled and most
likely long term black will regain one
of them
doubled and troubled yeah
yeah
well it was a twitter twitter audience
they they said you know when when the
porn a double pawn is in trouble stop it
isn't it it's troubled yeah
and uh when a double pawn is good never
score on a double point
so you know
we've got to write everything our
creative viewers now uh let's take a
look at the results so far you guys it's
a chaotic day with quarterfinals with
games going on back to back and uh it's
my eyesight is getting really bad but
yonder pogba and vincent keimer they are
currently playing game three they have
played two draws so far and they are
tied when they now are playing game
three um dingley ran he won the first
game against the artemyev they are still
in game two the bar is
roughly to the middle in game two but
ding up by one point magnus as we know
he won the first game second game was a
draw game three just started and
asipenko and hansen as we saw they have
played two draws uh game two just
finished so in about 10 minutes game
three will start for those two so now
you're up to speed
on what's going on
yeah so if we do see tie breaks it's
going to be
super exciting and it's looking likely
definitely yeah definitely meanwhile
those doubled pawns are well one of
them's about to drop one of them was
doomed anyway black's knight coming out
to target one of the double pawns and it
has given up its own life just to
isolate some of the black pawn so that
white pawn stepping forward
if black captures it which i'm expecting
then black's pawn structure isn't ideal
either
black does have a double set uh set of
double horns black does have some
isolated pawns which are now attacked by
white's knight as well yeah who would
you choose here well one thing i've
really uh been impressed with and you
i've learned from magnus carson's
approach to the game in general is that
i think he knows this position very well
but no computer i would imagine would
suggest that white should play this way
um you know just looking at the computer
assessment and magnus does this in a lot
of his games he he doesn't always follow
the computer's top choice he'd rather
head for a position he's very
comfortable in even if his opponent's a
little bit better as we saw in the world
championships and this is something i
feel only magnus has brought to chess
you know really heading into positions
he likes playing even if you're not
really getting a computer advantage even
if you're a little bit worse of black
and he loves certain positions and he's
kind of got that here he's got the
position he wants he's got kind of an
end game he's got maybe some chances to
push um because black's pawn structure
does have that slightly double pawn and
um it just shows you you don't always
follow the computer's top choice and end
up in a position you might not be
comfortable in it's better to go for the
computer second third fourth choice and
end up in a position that you're not
losing in but you're comfortable playing
and this is just forgotten so much at
lower level i feel because everyone's
like computer junkie now aren't they
what does the computer say what's the
computer doing and it's like just turn
it off sometimes and uh look with your
with your own eyes and uh um yeah magnus
does this uh fantastically well
yeah um that's a great point simon uh
the number of times i've played
opponents who just look at the first
line of the computer and then they say
to me oh why didn't you play this and i
just remind them yeah but
i mean you knew it anyway
i've seen it the first line you've seen
as the first line why would i go into
something that we both know
uh it would just fizzle out to a draw so
you're completely right and now magnus
just doing magnus things just bringing
the king to a better square connecting
the white rooks
and
somehow white bishop is better than the
black bishop white's knight looks great
right now white's rooks have easier
access to open files than blacks do just
all of these small things might add up
later in the game still nothing really
to write home about nothing special but
if anyone can milk out a win from this
position is magnus right
yeah magnus the in-game maestro
absolutely um yeah i have to say i do i
do agree with you it's like slightly
more pleasant for white but
at the same time i can also see black
holding this
and then you know yeah black black
should also be comfortable but i
wouldn't be comfortable playing magnus
here i mean as black i mean you can't
lose this position that's what you've
got to remember so it's a great position
to be in from the white point of view
because okay you draw you know you just
have to avoid losing the next game but
you can push you can push because you've
got a little bit more space a little bit
better pawn structure slightly better
pieces here black's pieces a bit passive
so of course you shouldn't lose this but
i wouldn't really want to defend this
one you know pretty much against anyone
but especially uh against magnus he's
got the position that he wants to get
and it's very easy for him to play so
not comfortable here and i do think like
the
potential pressure on the open b line
could
be something that scares black and maybe
kind of encourages him to make a mistake
yeah so i mean just like i mean for
example if you go i was just thinking
here if you go rook a b8 this could be
quite a big mistake uh because there's
knight b3 or at some stage and you can't
play your a5 move and if the white
knight heads that square it's very
subtle but if the white knight gets this
square
you can see black getting in in a lot of
difficulty and it's a very natural move
to put the rook on an open file uh but
it could be a slight mistake i'm not
sure it is but it's uh it's it's hard to
play in cramped positions as well and
black is more cramped here which is a
another issue he has so yeah yeah and if
this is the best he can do putting his
rook on a square like this blocked by
its own pawn then i don't think liam is
too comfortable with his position uh now
magnus as you mentioned about it's all
about the b-file he brings this rook
across and rather than go for the move
simon deemed a possible mistake liam has
i mean agreeing with you there uh liam
has just lifted up his rook instead and
magnus
he's getting ready to bring this guy
into the party uh inviting it all the
way across where the two rooks will
double up against the black bishop so
this is looking very powerful also i
guess if the black knight jumps forward
to attack this rook the rook can have
the option of sliding across eyeing up
this pawn rendering this black passive
just forcing it to stick in the corner
still a small advantage for white but it
is growing potentially and very
unpleasant for black to deal with
this looks like a game where both
players are sort of attacking uh with
only one piece for each player on the
back rank
yeah that's true
but then again if you look at all of
black's pieces on the seventh rank up
there they're not that active yeah
whereas whites do have the potential to
jump forward yeah and the two white
rooks now are teaming up to attack that
black bishop so liam needs to react does
he retreat his bishop does he step it to
the side does he use his knight to
defend it yeah and one mistake that you
probably should not make is actually
just put your rook behind the bishop
because if you do that
not only do you put yourself in a pin
but you allow yourself to be vulnerable
to sort of knight takes pawn checks and
that's why liam just offers a trade of
bishops now this does look good but it
does concede a few squares
this is right yeah yeah i mean if the
rooks get exchanged also black's brook
which moved to the side is so passive
there we've got to remember this this
maneuver with the white knight uh you
know let's say the brooks come off here
um and black moves the king out of the
pin uh this this little night maneuver
sets up a nasty a nasty threat okay he's
moved the king first
you shouldn't give your opponent access
to the sen frank but just to show your
idea simon the knight can drop back and
there's ideas for example of rook takes
night some sacrifices and this is so
tricky now because white's knight is
jumping in with a fork a double attack
and white will end up with an extra
piece so yeah you're gonna say simon in
the current position yeah i mean i'm
just comparing the pieces and i really
like this last move we talked about
black stubble pawns but one of the
problems with black's double pawns is he
has and what we call an isolated pawn a
lone soldier on the side of the board
this this poor little guy you know he's
wandering around without any protection
at all and uh the white king is just
heading towards that pawn and just wants
to take it very simple you know so yeah
i talked about two weaknesses just a few
minutes ago in a different game and look
at this black does have two weaknesses
he has to stop the white rooks
penetrating uh from this side but then
he also has has this huge weakness of
the isolated pawn on the other side of
the board and black is stretched now i
don't really understand this last move
to be honest unless the idea after
white's king comes forward is to bring
the black rook up maybe to cut the white
king off break its access to the fifth
rank but it feels so shaky by black
well we're gonna see it really hanging
by a thread already and okay we do see
this position white king cannot yet
march forward and pick off this pawn but
it might get that chance later in the
game at least black is activating that
rook if it comes over two squares you
can start attacking something it's the
first time black's attacked anything the
whole game uh pretty much so you know
that's that's something activating your
pieces and we talked about your rooks
need to be activated so
it's a it's
i think pretty pretty decent-ish idea
yeah actually the more i looked at it
the more i think maybe it was the only
idea to survive it happens have you
tried a fork here yeah um
i don't know yeah you can fork the
knight and rook at the same time a
double attack but then
white can counter-attack with his rook
and step forward can i sorry something
just occurred to me
if you go rook g5 oh no i've dropped my
pawn
oh dear i've lost the pawn magnus of
course takes the pawn because you know
it's it's a free pawn thank you very
much and oh i better retreat my knight
all the way back let's bring it back and
then magnus what is he doing i'm gonna
i'm gonna push
yeah let's go and attack that pawn and
yes
i'm really setting this up in like a
really impossible way but it's it's a
weird weird like uh and it's not even
checkmate nice one simon
but you get a draw
you know so cool that was really worth
it wasn't it
so it's a good point that the white king
isn't entirely safe despite going on
this adventure despite there being no
black pieces around it yet the white
king does have to uh watch out for some
stuff so um yeah i think right now the
first thing i would calculate in every
position checks captures threats there's
no checks there's no captures so it
would be this threat the double attack
but then again after this rook move
counter attacking against the black rook
if we do see some trades here then now
notice how yes white is maybe in a bit
of a semi-pin but black's rook from the
fifth rank has gone so white king does
have the opportunity to step forward and
go for the black pawns so that is why
black doesn't get tempted by any funny
business he just moves his king back to
the center and still this black rook
keeps an eye it's the guardian
of this fifth rank it's the only good
piece for black but for now it's doing a
good defensive job
and the black knight can think about
jumping forwards
i really do like simon's idea
i shouldn't be looking at checkmate in
here really but
you know i just see the white king is
kind of like you know it's a very active
piece but you have to guard your king
very carefully even in the ending and
you know you just have to be aware of
that sometimes but i don't think it's an
issue here in actual fact but maybe
black is holding the balance you know i
think he's done this idea of activating
the rook was very clever i feel yeah for
black and uh whilst we're waiting for
magnus to reply i just wanted to share
with you one selfie from marcus griego
who thanks us for the entertainment and
says mini masters luke and nicola were
there blunder master dad
did you both have dads that played chess
um yeah yeah yeah yeah definitely so um
london masters
my dad yeah um he was pretty good i mean
uh that was one of the reasons i took up
chess actually i remember he you know he
played it a lot and uh
it was great when i was you know like
eight nine and he took me to chess clubs
and you could stay up late you know you
just passed my bedtime but you go out
and play some chess and it was yeah it
was it was yeah how i got better and i
still play the same openings now that he
taught me when i was like seven years
old so but i haven't really developed
over the last 30 or years but anyway
it's uh you know it's it's good to have
that so yeah
yeah it seems that that is you know
often how it starts for for very very
many people and many kids it is with a
mother father or grandfather grandmother
that teaches them and just sparks that
fire to
to fall in love with chess yeah even
players who maybe don't play too
seriously and they kind of leave the
game but then they come back to it years
later it's often uh the first thing they
talk about is how yeah they used to sit
by the fire with their grandparents
that's really nice yeah
um yeah my dad taught me the moves but
he barely played and
i think i beat him within the first hour
when i was five years old and he said
okay never again and we never played
another chess game against youtube
really after that first hour
but you immediately showed the
big talent then but i'm still unsure
whether he let me win or whether i
actually generally won but then we never
played again so that makes me think oh i
don't know
but yeah i mean you're right kaya it's
uh it's just this bond with chess and if
it's forged in a way like that then
it's uh it's gonna be for a lifetime
yeah it's fantastic with chess as well
right because uh it doesn't matter what
ages you are you know kids can play with
grandparents or parents and and they can
keep playing for for
the entire life and even when the kid
gets really good you can always have
some sort of handicap right so you can
keep playing and competing in some way
yeah and it it doesn't matter what age
you are i mean it just translates
everything yeah i think it's you know
you translate your age or your religion
where you are in the world you know
everything when you sit at the board
nothing else matters and there's again
there's not many games
that can do that you know so just forget
about your background everything else
you're just playing on the board and
it's a beauty of chess you can just lose
yourself uh in the squares and that's
that's what i find beautiful is uh you
know it's meditation for me you know you
sit down you lose yourself in the game
and you find it fascinating so it's uh
it's yeah it's it's really good for that
and on the age topic i recently saw a
picture of the world's oldest
grandmaster who turned 100 a couple of
weeks ago and there was a picture of him
playing i think it was like a
six-year-old so it's like an
100 year old playing a six-year-old is
uh yeah i mean
that's why we love chess yeah what an
incredible game this is you guys and
it's intense uh in this competition the
air things master it's magnus crosston
fighting to qualify for the semi-finals
he's gonna need a win in this game or in
the fourth game or only a draw in the
fourth game liam leia he is down by one
point he needs to win one of these two
last rapid games to take his tie breaks
any chances for that in this game
possibly at least if we believe the
evaluation bar
i'm surprised i'm trying to understand
to be honest why the evaluation bar has
gone off in black's favor still not by
much but it does mean that maybe magnus
has given a small opportunity to liam to
activate his pieces and i think that
involves a combination of some of the
ideas we've already been discussing so
just to explain what's going through
liam's mind
as he ticks down on the clock it's a
rather worrying clock situation i was
about to say he could combine maybe
bring this knight around towards the
white king
with ideas such as pushing this pawn
forward he's gone for a different idea
however bringing his rook across and
he's going for white's isolated pawn
here but then again he has abandoned his
own isolated pawn on the side of the
board so a bit of a risky one there by
liam and
yeah i think it's mainly the clock
situation that will stop him winning
this game or at least even creating
anything
uh it still feels slightly easier for
white to play as long as white avoids
any tricks to do with the white king for
example or to do with any forks double
attacks that we mentioned there could be
a draw for this as well because i i
guess if you defend that pawn black goes
back you go back to the open file i mean
uh i was thinking even ruxin possibly is
just keep the knight in the center i
can't really can't really see anything
better than defending the pawn again and
you could have a repetition here uh if
if you if you want to but i i doubt
magnus would take a draw here i mean
it's kind of you know he's going to try
to find everything he can to play on
yeah uh to you know to try and win
black's straggling pawn on the side of
the board there yeah and it would be
very unlike magnus to firstly play a
passive move although here it's probably
required you have to defend this pawn uh
but secondarily yeah to take a draw in a
position where he has five minutes extra
on the clock with the white pieces and
with the better pawn structure kind of
he loves his long-term strategic uh kind
of pluses and it's still
if if the rooks come off remember
black's pawn on the side of the board is
the big target also this pawn so
long-term magnus is doing well i think
he'll try and
get complicated and i was going to say
he doesn't like to go passive so he
takes his pawn aligned black to grab a
pawn
and will we see it we do see it it's a
king march magnus is king leading from
the front going for these black belts oh
that looks scary
it is scary for i would say both white
and black
it's allowing uh black to get active
with his pieces and yes that king is
very impressive but if it gets caught in
no man's land then it's going to be
checkmate and you also had a king
checkmated on that square all right okay
not bring back those memories anymore
today please
we've heard it enough already
again no it was actually a beautiful
game you played and uh yeah it was i
tried to get active but i didn't
actually just check mate to me in a
lovely game but yeah this is incredibly
risky i i i mean
you know it's very brave but you you can
get overconfident and uh hang a bit look
at what magnus has just done he gave up
his rook magnus carlsen a bit of an
invisible move there he gave up his rook
drawing away the black rook and now he's
played knight takes pawn with a check
and a fork so now black's king has to
move away and then white will regain the
rook so a temporary sacrifice there by
magnus but as you mentioned simon it's
risky because the black king's gonna
come round now and white's king actually
does have some serious threats against
it potentially uh also white's knight
once it recaptures the black rook is
gonna be really offside it's there's no
coordination between white's pieces i
was hoping white would play g4 for some
really sadistic
idea there i don't know why g4 here push
gary go on um i don't know it's always
interesting to find checkmate patterns
uh just because it helps you uh you know
work out what's going on in the position
and uh that well black black would just
check this worst move on the board so
i don't think white will play it um but
okay i mean black black seems uh
defended very well here so far yep
hitting the white knight hitting this
pawn as well i'm slightly surprised that
we didn't see
a more ambitious move especially because
liam is one point down in today's match
for example just taking off this white
central pawn this pawn could be a
strength but it could well just be a
weakness later anyway and also there are
ideas such as uh maybe pushing this pawn
forward dropping the knight back with
some tracks also you can go on the
second rank with your rook later on it
feels like the central pawn maybe was
the mo uh more important of the two but
liam goes for the safety first approach
he brings his rook across the knight
drops back and okay he brings his king
forward so he will try and gobble up
this pawn soon but white does have an
opportunity to save the central pawn now
and uh who would you rather be here now
because
white has definitely lost control two
pawns under fire white's still temp uh
pawn up but
black yeah you take that
black and the primary reason is because
the white king is out there it's gone
rogue it's in no man's land and i think
it's in grave danger
yeah i think practically speaking uh
black's piece is all hitting targets and
uh
you know that that white kit it just
scares me having the white king there uh
in the position and again if you push
the g pawn here two squares you get
checkmated uh obviously this won't occur
but there's there's danger
uh to to to the white position here you
have to be a little bit careful yeah and
actually after the moves played the pawn
stepping forward and black taking the
spawn
i mean i'm terrified now with white i
mean if this pawn disappears the white
king is definitely trapped it's going to
be cut off on the edge of the board we
do see a trade and now white can take a
pawn with his king but be careful
because after rook takes pawn there's
going to be all sorts of checkmating
ideas against the white king now
i mean this white king we were praising
it for being fearless a few moves ago
but
it's that fine line isn't there between
like you know uh genius and madness but
also being fearless and just being a
complete plonker and uh i don't think
magnus is often a plonker in the way he
plays but you've got to be very careful
and uh he has to he had to play this
passive move there to stop black's rook
uh getting active and and coming in to
create some nasty net there but
you know you've got to be careful as
white definitely yeah this rook now a
terrible piece but it had to be done as
simon says guarding this pawn in front
of it and khan liam organized his knight
to come in he does he attacks this pawn
now also going towards the white king
magnus big defensive job ahead for him
to save this game at some point he needs
to just rush back with the white king
and pray that there are no uh traps
along the way would you take that pawn
uh you know does the pawn that the white
king can take
would you take that board whoa i mean
the problem that i see here in this
position is um how is white going to
defend
the pawn that's under attack the f4 pawn
step back with the white king step back
with the king and just yeah come get
back to safety but even then it doesn't
it feels a little bit shaky
yeah i mean if you step back you you've
got to find a move against the rook
coming to attack the pool as well um but
i think i would be stepping back here
whatever like i mean even if you might
be able to take that pawn there i i
would be too scared too
it just looks like your king is is is
going to be in trouble forever though
the journey wouldn't guess the journey's
been exciting enough the white king
needs to run the top move of the
computer to take the pawn is to take the
pawn oh wow
not human though silly computer no fear
at all so this is actually how you can
uh sometimes online there's a bit of a
pro oh he's taking it he's taking it
king takes porn look at that white king
right now
it's in mortal danger but
maybe it's surviving because you know
knight takes pawn here and what you do
with the g pawn so if the black knight
takes that pawn
you know you have to be so careful your
next move is yes there is oh maybe
there's a pin white's rook can step
across but then black can just defend
that knight with his pawn then g3 is
checkmate again which is there's always
this idea of checkmate to the black king
we might well see it if white steps
forward with the pawn now to attack the
black knight we would have seen
checkmate in one move what's he going
for wow magnus he is trying to he's
going to sacrifice everything he's going
to get rid of black's remaining pawn oh
wow we might see rook and knight versus
rook and that's a draw
i've actually had that exact end game
against liam myself
but you know
that is clever
wow it's so so
delicate calculation there because you
you miscalculate even slightly you're
just a piece down so where you've got to
be so confident to play play in this
manner uh
unbelievable i mean knight and rook
versus uh rook is is a draw uh bishop
and brooke is much harder to draw but
there has been cases where one side has
lost defending that i think it was uh
actually uh was it judit pogo kasparov
she lost um she lost with the with the
rook so uh and there was a story bobby
fischer had this ending as well so let's
imagine all the pawns are removed from
the board and you're just left with the
pieces and there's a story that bobby
fisher was playing someone they went
into this ending and his opponent
offered him a draw because of course
it's a draw and and bobby just said i'm
a piece up don't ask me again
don't know if that's true or not but i i
someone told me that and uh yeah you've
got to defend still so yeah the white
king's over in the corner some chances
yeah possibly and now liam has two
kind of options he can either move the
black knight out of the way it is
attacked and then white's rook will go
and remove the remaining black pawn from
the position or black's rook can swing
across and take a pawn with check
but then the white king will move
towards that remaining black pawn and
that black pawn is going to fall off the
board we will see that end game rook and
knight against a rook and that will go
on for 50 moves i'm pretty sure uh liam
will try everything he can
i played him in st louis in the u.s
in 2019 he had a rookie night against my
rook in a classical game a long play
game and he played for 50 moves until it
was no longer possible until i could
claim a draw uh he tried to beat me i
managed to hold it in the end but
um yeah i think we're going to see that
end game and liam just checking that he
can't keep the black pawn alive but i
don't think he can hmm well we have one
big result in uh another quartz final
match jana pogniacci has won game three
against vincent keimer that means nepo
is up by one point in that match and it
also means that vincent kaimer he has to
win game four to take that one to tie
breaks if it is a draw or a win for nepo
then the russian will be ready for
semi-finals
all right
and this one magnus with a
draw here it's looking good for him with
a win it's going to be over isn't that
even possible a win for magnus in this
game now no okay
he is fighting for for a draw he's
fighting for a draw and barring some
finger
slip or mouth slip or anything then
he will get the draw okay
but it could be a long game then it will
be a long game going to be i
unfortunately don't think it's going to
hit 100 moves because now we're at move
38 the pawns will disappear the pawns
have just disappeared it is rooker
knight against a rook so now the magical
number will be
move
let's wait for it move
89. okay okay yeah it just disappeared
on the last move or move 39 so there's
50 moves now liam has to win
either by checkmate or win the white
rook otherwise the game will be declared
a draw and uh i mean they have
sufficient time right well okay liam is
down to is it three and a half minutes
uh on the clock
it's that sort of sufficient uh the time
to keep uh you know fighting
definitely yeah it is it is sufficient
time the problem is that defensive
technique is pretty straightforward
though for
for white i mean it's just all about
checking the king and you know you check
from the side you check from behind
behind is a really good way to check
i did see actually only two weeks ago uh
one of england's best players
gwen jones had this in a tournament
online and he lost to hikaru in this
ending actually oh um hikaru tricked him
but i i think with a time situation uh
you know magnus can if he gets to a
position where he has to make a decision
he can he can spend that little bit of
extra time and i i don't see any way he
will lose this but you know you've got
to play on if you're a piece up yeah and
just to explain the defensive maneuver
at some point you will get cut off on
the side of the board with your king
white's king will look like it's about
to get checkmate uh checkmated but
that's when as yvang mentions a check
will come or the white rook will pin the
black knight and then no matter where
the black king goes the white king will
go the other way the black king goes one
way the white king will run
to the side so even getting cut off on
the side of the board it's not really an
issue here
like it is in some end games for example
rook and bishop versus rook where you
really have to be precise if your king
is near the edge of the board
and uh so talking about long long games
david as you mentioned you were getting
very excited when you heard the the
number 100 come up
now
but you get more excited number 200
don't you i mean you had this famous
famous game where you nearly broke the
world
so record many moves did your game go on
for i think it was 236. but 236. you
think and yeah 236.
the world record is 269 but that was
played in the days where the 50 move
rule was a 100 mover absolutely i don't
think that should count i have a feeling
you will be going for that world record
when the match against no score and
elliott starts in a week probably when
i'm commenting
yeah
10 hours later
david plays another move
and niels plays another move and yes
thank you very much david
i can confirm we're playing the same
time control as uh the world
championship now okay nice for half of
the games and then a shorter time
control for the other half but the first
half is the long time control so you
could see a repetition for example of
magnus carlton against the underpoint
actually game six yeah where it was
130 something i moved yeah it's nearly
eight hours i would but i'm going to put
a bet on that you'll beat 130 whatever
moves it was i i can guarantee you'll
have one game over 138 moves i know the
way you milk you play you grind them
down
if you're watching get ready
[Laughter]
bring coffee bills you're gonna need it
and meanwhile look at this the white
king has been cut off on the top rank on
the eighth rank but as we mentioned
there's no way for black to create a
checkmating net around that white king
because anytime the black king goes over
towards the white king the white king is
going to run to one of the sides or the
black king will just get checked
so yeah you can get this far but you're
not going any further
and liam he's built up a bit of time
he's made a few very very quick moves to
gain those 10 seconds on the clock and
uh he's trying to work out whether there
are any tricks in the position
usually the tricks do involve getting
the white king right into the corner but
even that is a draw so
okay he steps back with the black king
and now if the white rook continues
checking then the black king will at
least be able to hide behind its own
knight
but even that is
even as a draw problem
but probably not a good idea to allow it
it's easier just to keep the rook
keep the king cut off with the rook
so white for example can just wait in
this position he does check he checks
yeah this is fine too but now the black
king will move towards the white king
and actually create a checkmating threat
if black's king does shuffle
to the right one square black's rook
will threaten to go up and check mate
checks will continue and white's king
will escape
it's important for the white king to run
to the center
you know just in case remember that's
that
line from arrested development run for
the seas
that's what you've got to always
remember don't get your king stuck in
the corner because then it's in danger
of getting checkmated yeah yeah i think
that's a good rule in general any of any
end game kings towards the center if in
doubt if you have five seconds in your
clock you have to decide don't put it in
the corner go towards the center
and uh okay liam meanwhile spending a
bit of time trying to work out
a uh a trap that magnus might fall into
i don't think he will but he did the
same against me he had plenty of time
when we reached the same game a couple
of years ago and he just sat there
trying to work out the defense uh the
the way to break my defenses i think i
had 30 seconds on the clock and he had
like 45 minutes and he was just sitting
there surprised how do i check meet you
you get a cup of tea out have a sip
and leave you there with one i think i
was the one doing that actually really
even with 30 seconds left 30 seconds is
it like loads of time
okay
oh look at that they they jump to the
other side of the board there so yeah
it's impressive small delay there but
the moves did come and white's king as
we mentioned as soon as the black king
went towards it one side the white king
went the other way and uh now look at
this the white rook couldn't check the
black king because the checks were
blocked by black's knight and this is a
key defensive technique you go to the
other side black's knight can't block
both checks from
both vertical checks and horizontal
checks
so it's a good way to try and annoy the
opponent's king so check white's king
will step back and attack that rook
so just slide one square across
but uh
still no danger yet if the white king
goes to the corner or is forced into the
corner then maybe some chances okay and
lee i'm trying to do that yeah the check
yup defending his rook now white's king
again forced onto one of the sides of
the board
yeah i mean i think even in this ending
we're seeing that the the activity of
the rook is so important and if magnus
keeps that rook as far away uh from the
king and knight he's going to be okay
if you bring that rook towards the black
king that's when it gets dangerous
because you run out of squares for your
rook so you've got to you've got to
distance yourself and that's why rooks
are so much more powerful
in the ending than they are you know in
the opening stage of the game um and not
much progress being made here but we
we've got a we've got still some moves
to go to so uh yeah and the white king
is now gonna start uh making its bid for
freedom there you go yeah
move up the board and move 89 right
um game three between ding and artemyev
just started ding is up by one point if
he wins this game he's going to be ready
for the semifinals uh our time he needs
at least a draw and etibenko hansen game
three also started between those two and
i think maybe the bar is slightly over
to our canson side and they are tied
after the two first games jana pogniacci
is up by one point against kymer in game
four between those two will be starting
in just a few minutes and that's going
to be a must-win situation for the
german 17 year old
and simon you mentioned that good point
of keeping white's rook as far away as
possible also that avoids any night
forks any double attacks um i've seen
plenty of blitz games end that way just
white's rook and white's king just
within distance of each other and the
black knight gets to attack them both at
the same time but it's actually a
similar thing if you take the black
brook off the board and you're just
playing you're trying to win with the
rook against the knight you've got to
keep the king and knight close together
so it's like just these little rules uh
that if you know them in the ending
it'll make your job of defending uh a
lot easier uh but yeah white's just
keeping the rook as far away as he can
here so it doesn't get a nasty fork
and we've all fallen for a fork at some
point in our lives haven't we many times
many many times
and backward night moves oh all these
painful ones nights are so tricky
they're such tricky it's such tricky
pieces
especially when you don't have so much
time in the clock you know they're
saying if you've got less than 30
seconds left and you're not getting time
added a knight is almost worth more than
a rook yeah which is crazy because just
of this whole kind of circular movements
i learnt that to my costs when i was
playing against magnus age 10 i lost my
rook to a backwards night move so
definitely some stuff to watch out for
and uh simon you mentioned it even if
black loses his rook here for free yeah
he's still a draw instead of drawing
yeah then we could see another 50 moves
and then we'd reach the magical 100 yeah
mark but uh yeah i mean
yeah but is it you said move 89 correct
so after black's 89th move the game is a
draw okay eight more moves left i think
so yeah right yeah
so uh yeah and notice how white's king
it was trapped on one side of the board
but there was no way to break through so
liam tried to flip the board so white's
king is on another side now he's just
trying to confuse magnus by putting the
white king on different sides of the
board sometimes visually it's quite hard
but the problem is
it's just so hard to combine all of
black's pieces together
um they're defending each other now but
there's no way to trap the white king on
the edges so yeah really instructive
anyone at home trying to learn how to
defend the same game play through this
game look at knight vs rook it does
happen actually a fair amount yeah and
white's king now just attacking the
black rook he's running out of moves
liam as well yeah there's only only
about six more moves to to go here so as
long as uh wow something outrageous
doesn't happen it will be
getting to that draw very very shortly
um i think yeah we're seconds away now
from the result yeah i don't think
either of these players know how close
we are to 50 but the computer um just
the interface of the truss24 interface
that uh interface they're playing on
will declare the draw automatically okay
once we hit black's 89th move all right
so it's getting very close and that
means it's also getting quite close to a
semi-final for magnus carlsney only
needs a draw in game four
but he will have the black pieces and
he has to go for the win in that game to
have chances to take it to tiebreak so
that should be a very very interesting
game for coming up and then 15 minutes
after the last move in this game
okay so just a couple more moves now
this is really brave by magnus actually
walking his king into the eye line of
the black rook allowing what we call a
discover check but here the white rook
is far enough away that there's no
where for the black knight to attack it
so i think they had a very strange
incident i think it was in the european
uh championships or some tournament
recently whereas checkmate in one move
forced but they had made 50 moves so
it's actually a draw i can't remember
the competition now so even if you've
got a force checkmate it's like are they
drawn there sorry yeah